Good afternoon.
I'm Phillip Khoury.
I'm Associate Provost at
MIT with responsibility
for the arts.
And I want to welcome all of
you to this public presentation
by Robert Lepage, who is the
recipient of the 2012 Eugene
McDermott Award in
the Arts at MIT.
We're very pleased
also to have with us
Peter Gelb, the general manager
of the Metropolitan Opera.
We look forward to a
stimulating and lively dialogue
about technology and
stagecraft and storytelling.
Before introducing our
distinguished guests,
let me say a few words about
the McDermott Award, which
is one of the most generous arts
prizes in the United States.
Established in 1974
by Margaret McDermott
to honor her late husband,
Eugene, co-founder of Texas
Instruments, the award
recognizes individuals
whose artistic trajectory
and body of work
indicate that they will
achieve the highest
distinction in their fields.
The award is considered an
investment in the recipient's
future creative
work, rather than
a prize for a particular project
or a lifetime of achievement.
Most of all, however
the McDermott Award
reflects MIT'S commitment
to risk-taking,
problem solving, and
connecting creative minds
across disciplines.
I want to especially thank
Mary McDermott Cook, daughter
of Margaret and
Eugene McDermott,
who is here this evening--
this afternoon, late evening--
in the front row here.
She continues the great
commitment of her family
to the arts here at MIT
in their hometown, Dallas,
and in many, many other places.
Mary, delighted you're here with
us to help honor Robert Lepage.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, recounting just a few
aspects of Robert Lepage's work
will reveal why he is such an
ideal recipient of this award.
Lepage's multidisciplinary
work defies categorization.
As you will have learned from
the extraordinary array of work
in the timeline that was
projected as you entered
this auditorium, Mr.
Lepage is equally
talented as a playwright,
actor, film director,
and stage director.
He and his production
company, Ex Machina,
have toured numerous
productions internationally
to critical and popular acclaim,
from large multiple part
productions to one person plays,
including the Anderson Project,
recently presented in
Boston by Arts Emerson.
He has created two Cirque
Du Soleil productions, KA,
a resident show at MGM
Grand in Las Vegas,
and TOTEM, which will be
seen in Boston in June.
He has acted in or directed
numerous feature films.
He stage directed two musical
tours for rock star Peter
Gabriel, who I just learned
was here at our Media Lab
just yesterday.
He has created spectacular
outdoor illuminations
and architectural
projections in Quebec Harbor,
using the surface of the
Bunge grain elevators
as a giant screen.
Spectacular, really.
And you will understand
why Lepage's work resonates
with the creative values
of the MIT community.
We at MIT particularly
admire his willingness
to cross disciplinary boundaries
in the pursuit of innovation.
The collaborative
enterprise that
drives his creative output.
His relentless experimentation
with new technologies in order
to reimagine for
the 21st century
the ritual origins of
multiple performance genres.
Including, of course, opera,
which some people would say
is inherently the most
multidisciplinary of performers
for performance genre.
Which brings me to our second
distinguished guest today--
Peter Gelb.
Since becoming general manager
of the Metropolitan Opera
in 2006, Peter Gelb has
launched a host of initiatives
to revitalize the Met and to
connect it to a wider audience.
Under his leadership,
the company
has recruited many of
the world's great theater
directors, including
Robert Lepage.
He also increased
the annual number
of new productions, secured more
performances from top singers,
and he launched the trailblazing
Peabody Award-winning series,
the Met Live in HD, which
presents live performance
transmissions in movie
theaters around the world.
I'm interested to note that much
earlier in his career in 1978,
Peter Gelb was an assistant
manager of the Boston Symphony
Orchestra.
So, perhaps, one could say
that his illustrious career was
launched right here in Boston.
In any case, he has won six
Emmy Awards and three Peabody
Awards since then.
We owe special thanks to Mr.
Gelb for being here today,
since he must return to New York
immediately after this program
in order to make the curtain
for a performance tonight of Das
Rheingold, the first opera
in Wagner's four part
Der Ring des Nibelungen.
Directed by Robert Lepage,
the four operas in the cycle
have been presented over
the last two seasons,
and are being
presented this month
and in May as a complete
cycle for the first time.
Now Robert Lepage first began
directing opera in 1993,
and first collaborated
with the Metropolitan Opera
in 2008 and 2009 in that season,
when he directed La Damnation
de Faust--
The Damnation of Faust
by Hector Berlioz.
Lepage's production used
an innovative combination
of virtual scenery,
interactive video projections,
and aerial acrobatics
to dramatize
the timeless melodramatic
plot of sin and redemption.
His transformation of
Wagner's 16 hour Ring Cycle,
however, is the most
ambitious production
the Met has ever attempted.
The four works in the
cycle are Opera's most
challenging and
transcendent epic.
The Met's new production,
which premiered
between September
2010 and January 2012,
uses the groundbreaking
single set
comprised of 24
movable planks, which
together with
computerized projections
form every mythic scene and
action that Wagner imagined.
We at MIT appreciate
the ambition
of this undertaking, especially
the scale of imagination
and the technical complexity
that the new production
entails.
And we appreciate
the risk taking
involved in reconceptualizing
a revered masterpiece
in this way, including
the controversy
that such bold moves
can and will generate.
Productive disruptions of
norms are healthy and necessary
for innovation, for they
generate new thinking
and inventions for
the benefit of us all.
That's very Lepage,
and it's very MIT, too.
We look forward now to
hearing from these two
great creative
minds about the Ring
and other aspects of Mr.
Lepage's diverse and expansive
body of work.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please join me
in welcoming Robert
Lepage and Peter Gelb.
[APPLAUSE]
Not used to sitting
in such a deep--
[LAUGHS]
I don't know what controversy
you're talking about,
but I'm Peter Gelb,
this is Robert Lepage,
as I'm sure you know.
I am very happy to be here, to
have this conversation in front
of you with Robert.
It's true that my career
did begin in Boston,
but I haven't been here
much in recent years.
I mostly stayed in contact by
watching Yankee Red Sox games.
But I won't go any further.
I don't like gloating.
The Red Sox win.
They win their share.
When I was appointed to
the Met at the end of 2004,
I was determined to
reconnect the Met
to the cultural
mainstream, which
is not necessarily an easy thing
to do with an opera company
with 128 or
129-year-old history.
And that was in recent decades
not used to making much
in the way of change.
But I was determined
that we had to change
the very essence of what
we put on the stage,
and the way in which we
connected with our audiences,
both inside the opera house
and outside the opera house.
And I sought the help of a
number of leading directors.
But the person whose
help I sought, I think,
first, was Robert Lepage.
Because I had known his
work and I've known him
for about 20 years,
and I believed
that the way to change
the basic fabric of opera
required bringing in
great creative minds
and visionary people
with visionary ideas,
such as Robert.
And in fact, there's no
director in the world
that I know of
today who deserves,
I think, this prestigious
award more than Robert.
His visual imagination
and knack at storytelling
is what sets him apart from--
or, not to say there aren't
other great directors who
have great visual imagination
and are great storytellers.
But Robert's has
an individual voice
which is remarkable in that it
is also, no two projects of his
seem to bear any direct visual
connection to each other.
Each thing he does-- which
is very unusual, I think,
for directors-- each project
that he takes on really
has a soul and a life and
artistic character of its own.
So because of that, and
because of my knowledge
of Robert's career, I
sort of instinctively
understood that it
was he who I had
to go to direct the
Met's new Ring Cycle.
Which is, because of its scale
and sheer length of 16 hours
long, four operas,
is the single--
even if you don't
approach it on the scale
that Robert approached it on--
it's the largest undertaking
any opera company could possibly
take on.
And since I believe in
taking risks in order
to change the face of
opera and advance it,
I embraced and supported
all of Robert's
revolutionary technological
ideas for this ring,
even though sometimes it seemed
that my fate and the fortunes
of the Met were
swinging in the balance.
[CHUCKLES]
But.
But for a new Ring, I would
rather gamble with Robert
than with anybody else.
And in a few hours,
as Philip mentioned,
a few hours from now,
we're beginning the first
really tightly
scheduled Ring Cycle
of this new production,
which is why
I have to fly back to New York.
Robert wisely staying behind.
But his work has been done.
Last night, in fact, timed with
the opening of our new Ring
Cycles was the premiere of
a fascinating documentary
film about the making of this
Ring, in which documentary
filmmaker Susan Froemke spent,
I guess, about five years
following Robert and his team.
And because of my long
relationship with her
and trust in her, I gave
sort of complete access
to everything that
went on at the Met.
Almost complete access.
And the film premiered at
the Tribeca Film Festival
last night, and will be shown
in movie theaters later on.
In fact, next month.
But I thought it would
be interesting just
to get things rolling,
we have a lot of--
Robert has brought
a lot of video,
and his colleagues
have arranged for us
to see a lot of interesting
examples of his work.
But I thought just to give
you a sense of the scale
and scope of this new
Ring, a taste of it,
we would play this
trailer for the movie,
for this documentary, which
we're going to do so now.
If we could play the Wagner
Dream trailer, please.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Nothing defines an opera
house more than new productions.
Opera has to be constantly
renewing itself.
The Metropolitan Opera
kicks off its new season
with a lavish production of
Wagner's four-part Ring Cycle.
It's the most
ambitious production
the Met has ever mounted.
- This is as big as it
gets for an opera company.
- No new production
is more significant.
- The story of the Ring is the
creation and the destruction
of the world.
16 hours of opera.
This is an intense
challenge for any director.
- Robert Lepage.
One of theater's
great visionaries.
- We use state of the art tools
to present a really fresh, new,
avant-garde crazy ring.
- I went to Iceland, digging
into the Icelandic roots.
Tectonic sets, breaking
apart and separating,
suits the Scandinavian myths.
- I love Wagner.
I'm afraid of what they're
going to do with it, though.
- Parts of it have
always been unstagable.
Swimming underwater, walking
over rainbow bridges,
riding on winged horses.
- Nobody has gotten
it perfectly right.
- That's what
we're trying to do.
- Deborah Voigt, you'll
be singing Brunhilde
for the very first time.
- There were only one or
two or three Brunhildes
who can command the
stage at the Met.
- There are so many
challenging vocal passages.
It can be defining
in her career.
- It was so daunting
for such a time
that I thought, are
you out of your mind?
It's a very emotional
journey, this one.
- Have you seen those sets?
- I'm a little bit nervous
about standing on it.
[MACHINERY CLICKING]
- Stop it.
- Emergency stop!
- You were never in danger.
Everything was locked in.
- I don't want to lose
my feet or whatever.
- This is when the
real pros come out.
- You scared?
- I'm so scared, I'm sorry.
- Everything OK?
- So far, so good.
- I was compared
to being, you know,
kind of a Christopher Columbus.
You have to convince
a whole crew
that you're not going to fall
off the edge of the Earth,
that you are going to discover
something, you know it's there,
and you'll get there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- If this is what
opera is like--
- We want more.
[END PLAYBACK]
It's beautiful.
So that's just the
tip of the iceberg.
You can say that again.
So, Robert, why don't you--
I know that you believe
that storytelling
is more important than anything
else in anything you stage.
And technology obviously played
a huge part in this production.
But maybe you can
talk a little bit
about how you harness
the technology,
and why you harnessed
the technology that you
did harness.
And the story of how
you came to this.
Yeah.
Well, actually, I've
always been an artist
who had problems really
defining himself.
You know, I'm a stage director
but I'm also an actor,
I'm also a filmmaker.
Or I'm all of the
above, whatever.
But it's not important exactly
what I do for a living.
The idea is that I like mingling
with different people who
work in different disciplines.
And I think that the
opera, certainly-- well,
the stage in general--
but let's say
the opera more than theater,
more than dance, is a place,
is a great meeting point.
And Wagner spoke of
the gesamtkunstwerk.
He dreamed of the
gesamtkunstwerk, which means
the together artistic work.
Which is a literal
translation that
means the meeting
point, the gathering
of all sorts of people
from different disciplines.
And I really believe that opera
is the great multidisciplinary
way of working, way
of telling a story.
So of course, it's
always a question
of finding the
balance between who
tells what part of the
story, and what's redundant,
and what's overstated.
And so for me, the whole
technological research
or presence in my
work is just there
as a tool to merge these
disciplines together.
I work in a field, well,
I'm mainly a stage director
from the theater.
So that means I work a
lot in the live world.
But I'm also interested
by the recorded world.
I like doing films
once in a while,
and I like doing
television stuff.
And I think that in
the 21st century,
audiences are going to want
something more of theater
and something more of film.
And the qualities of theater
are being more and more asked
from the recorded medium,
which has become a kind of,
of course you have the
intimacy in movies because
of the close ups and all
that, and the great sound.
But you don't have the liveness,
the interaction, with film
that you have in theater.
And then vice versa.
With the theater
world, you don't
have the sense of intimacy if
you're in a 2000 seat room.
You're not as
close to the actor.
So how do you get all of
the advantages of film?
So I think that the way
for these two worlds
that are very, very close
cousins, because we're
dealing with actors, we're
dealing with writers,
with storytellers,
and we're trying
to convey the same
ideas, the same emotions.
I think that the more the
technology is the same,
that the more that the
lighting you use in film
and the lighting
that I use on stage
is the same
instruments, or the data
or the codes or any
kind of technology that
is being used in both
worlds is common,
then there's a dialogue.
Then there's an openness.
And then I believe that the
21st century will probably
be the scene of some
eighth form of art,
which will be a great
meeting point of all
of those disciplines.
And, of course,
this is one attempt.
The opera world is a
great place to try that.
It's full of traps
and obstacles,
but as we say in Buddhism, your
obstacles are your friends.
So, of course, I've made a lot
of friends on this experience.
But I believe in that, really.
I really believe in that.
I still believe in
the stage, I still
believe in people
gathering in the same room,
seeing artists taking
risks, because it's
a very, very risky thing.
And certainly opera is a sport.
And actually what I find
remarkable in your way
of presenting it in
the HD transmissions,
it is like an exciting hockey
game or an exciting football
game because you have
the singers concentrating
and stepping on stage,
singing their heart out.
And then as soon as they
walk off, you catch them
and you say, so how was it?
You know, and all that.
So it's a bit crazy,
but for some reason,
opera lends itself to that,
because it's a larger than life
effort.
It's a larger than life
way of telling a story.
And I think it's, I
really truly still believe
in opera and its potential.
It's just been ignored a bit,
or it hasn't been as accessible,
let's say, to everybody
in the past century
as it should have been.
But it used to be in the 19th
century much more accessible
and much more popular.
Well, obviously, I
mean, some the problems
are the length of operas--
Also.
--and the languages that you
have to read subtitles for.
It's sort of like going to
a foreign film or something.
You have to be able to over--
be willing to accept.
Absolutely, yeah.
There's a lot of conventions.
But that's the thing
that I find extraordinary
about the [? HG ?] transmissions
from my hometown, Quebec City,
the rooms are filled with people
who've never been to the opera
before.
You see grandfathers and their
children explaining the story.
Of course, it's in German
with English subtitles,
and they're French
speaking people.
I mean, of course.
But there's a passion,
there's a mystery there.
There's something that
seems to attract them.
So I think there's a
lot of hope in this.
Getting to the essence of the
Ring, when you, since this is
probably the single
biggest project
I guess you've undertaken, as
well as I have, at the Met.
There has been some,
as Philip mentioned,
some controversy
around it, which
seems to be mostly
out of your choice to,
even though you're using the
most modern technological means
to tell the story
that Wagner wrote.
As opposed to doing it in
some sort of more abstract,
metaphorical kind of fashion.
Yeah.
Well there's something, I mean,
very few people know this.
Is that I hope Wagner fans
or opera fans will eventually
have the chance to
read the whole score
and the whole
libretto of the Ring.
But it reads like a film script.
And--
Do you want to just--
I mean, I presume most people
know the story of the Ring,
but you want to give a--
[LAUGHING] You really
want me to put myself
through that exercise?
But--
We can tell it together.
No, but the thing
is, the reason why
I say it reads
like a film script,
is because what Wagner asks of
the stage designer and lighting
designer and the director,
what he asks of us is a movie.
And at a time where film--
And in fact, when Wagner
is, as was pointed out
in this documentary, when
Wagner created the Ring,
he built this theater to
put it on in Bayreuth,
and then produced it, but was
very unhappy with the results.
Of course.
Because he didn't have--
He couldn't, because
he had n-- he didn't
have the technological,
the technical means,
to represent the story,
this impossible story
that he had composed.
And it just means that he
was a Freudian before Freud.
He was cinematic before cinema.
So, you know, that's the
great genius of Wagner.
And so--
That's one of the reasons
why you decided to actually--
Absolutely.
And to put myself at the
service of these demands.
So, of course, there's
a lot of people
who think that there's no
personal vision of the Ring.
But for me, it's my entrance
into the Wagnerian world.
I have in front of me a monument
that's much bigger than myself,
and I want to learn from it.
So I tried to be as faithful
to the story as possible,
and in every detail.
And see how in this day and age,
if we do have the technology
to accomplish many,
many miracles,
how can we actually
illustrate these things?
And sometimes people have been
very critical of some elements
that I've staged that were
actually demands from Wagner.
Well, I think the
public loves it.
And the proof of that
is in the reaction
inside the opera house.
You know, we have some video
examples of some of the things
that you did, which
Wagner, as you said,
demanded or asked
for various actions
to be depicted that
opera houses, when
they produce the Ring never do.
Because they don't have the
scenery or the wherewithal
to do it.
So you, with this machine that
you and your designers created,
invented, set out
from the beginning
to be able to realize all these
scenic ideas of Wagner that
typically are heard musically,
but never actually represented
on the stage.
Exactly.
So do you want, is there
one you wanted to show?
Well, maybe, one of
the first excerpts
is maybe the descent
down into Valhalla.
Nibelheim.
Oh, no, sorry.
To Nibelheim.
Actually, there is a
huge chunk of music
where there's a suggestion
by Wagner where we actually
see Wotan.
So this, just to set the stage,
so Wotan, the King of the gods,
has reneged on his
deal with the giants
who built his new castle.
And he realizes, though, that
he's in a lot of trouble.
And to get out of it,
he and his aide de camp,
Loge, the God of fire, decide
to go down into the underworld
where Nibelheim, where Alberich,
the dwarf who was previously,
in the beginning of the
opera, has stolen the gold
from the Rhine, which sets off
this whole cataclysmic chain
of events.
Alberich is down in Nibelheim
with his fellow dwarves
making more treasure,
and planning
for an assault on the
gods and the powers above.
So Wotan goes down
there with Loge.
Normally this is not seen.
A curtain comes in and you
hear the music, and the next--
And you're supposed to imagine.
You're supposed to imagine it.
Of course, if you
know the libretto
and if you know the story.
So maybe you could
look at an excerpt.
Of course, we'll
be doing this a bit
accelerated, because the
excerpts can be a bit longish.
But we might speed
it up on the way
so you can get to
appreciate all of it.
Although this one might
wreak havoc with the museum.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So, in fact--
[APPLAUSE]
They eventually get there.
Yeah, they eventually get there.
Actually, maybe to give
you a sense of the scope,
we could watch another excerpt,
which is the excerpt at the end
of the Walküre, when Wotan
puts his daughter Brunhilde
to sleep.
It gives you maybe
a better scope
of what the whole project was.
And we should
point out that this
is one of the, maybe the
first opera, certainly
the first opera in the
history of the Met,
to utilize stunt doubles.
Also.
But some of the stunts have been
actually performed, sometimes,
by some of the performers.
Those were two acrobats.
Yeah, absolutely.
But--
We don't normally
send our singers--
But it happened at times
that some singers--
Unless you want to
get rid of them.
--some singers would show up
and look at the stunt and say,
I can do that.
And say, well, I'm
not sure you should.
But actually, we
actually got to do it.
So maybe we could look at
maybe another excerpt right
away just to give you a sense
of the scope of the, um.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
So what you've seen basically
is the end of Walküre--
The second opera.
And so what was very
challenging for us
is to try to create a
stage that has something
very traditional about
it, because it's actually
24 planks.
And when it starts,
it's in a rake position,
so it looks like a traditional
opera house raked floor.
And it all looks
very, very normal.
But then eventually,
when it starts
with the beginning of the
Rheingold and we try to--
normally it's the
music of the Rhine,
so we, the plank starts
rocking, and eventually become
very, very sensuous
water, and eventually
evolve into all sorts
of different locations.
And, of course, as the
story evolves, it becomes,
it illustrates many,
many, many things.
So what it was
inspired by, basically,
was the idea that some of
those-- well, most of the Ring
comes from the Icelandic Eddas.
And the Eddas are
pretty much like the,
kind of a Bible in Icelandic
and Viking culture.
So Wagner, we keep forgetting
that Wagner actually
borrowed those heroes
and these stories
to create the story of the Ring.
And because of that, and I've
been to Iceland a few times.
And I was struck by how,
because in a past life,
I was interested in
geography and geology.
And I was all into
tectonic plates
and the movement of continents
and volcanic activity,
and all that.
You did your show.
I even did a show
called Tectonic Plates.
And Iceland is, I don't know if
you've been to Iceland before,
but it's a tiny island
of a country that's
sitting in the
middle of the ridge
where actually, the world is--
America and Europe are
kind of separating.
And even the
country's separating.
Each year there's a
fault, and that opens
six centimeters each year.
So it's a moving place, and
the ground is a moving--
it's not a stable place.
And it has all
sorts of eruptions,
and all sorts of
states and all that.
And when you visit Iceland,
you have a very different take
on the Ring.
Because you go, oh, I
can understand somebody,
a culture living here and
imagining how all elements
manifest themselves.
And how they do believe
that there is a god of fire
and a god of thunder and a
god of this and a god of that.
So we wanted to create
something that would
be tectonic in a certain way.
There was some kind
of, where the ground
wouldn't be very
stable, which was very
alarming for a lot of singers.
[LAUGHS] Because they were,
oh, you're walking on something
that moves all the time.
The singer we just saw,
the end of Walküre,
was the singer Byrn
Terfel, who's Wotan,
the ruler of the gods
on the foreground.
And he was just sentenced
his daughter Brunhilde
for disobeying him to endless
sleep surrounded by fire.
On top of mountain.
On top of the mountain.
But that actual singer who
plays Brunhilde had exited,
and this was her stunt double.
Body double, yeah.
Sort of the operatic
equivalent of the piano drop.
[LAUGHING] The soprano drop.
So.
Yeah.
What else should we
talk about the Ring?
Do you want to talk about
a bit about the creation
of the design of the set?
Or do you have some animation
that could be, maybe--
Yeah, we have, just so
you understand a bit how,
the premise of all this.
We have a clip of the set
designer, Carl Fillion,
who's a set designer who is
actually an amazing stage
engineer.
I've been working with him
in Cirque Du Soleil a lot,
and doing some other
theatrical creations, actually.
But you work,
actually, with many--
we're going to get to
that in a little while.
But you're, unlike--
most directors
have one team they work with.
You work with many teams,
many different directors.
I mean, many
different designers.
Yes, absolutely.
Yeah.
Of course, Carl probably
was, for a long time,
the principal one.
Because I was asked
to do, I'm always
interested to do these big,
big shows and all that.
And Carl has, his
back is strong enough
to actually take
on these projects.
So maybe we could show some of
his 3D animations of the sets
so you'd understand a bit more.
And that's something we
could speed up, right?
Yeah, this we could speed up.
Yeah.
And it's actually-- so
this is the princess.
When we were saying
that it starts with the,
this is the beginning where
the Rhine maidens come out,
and of course, they're
suspended by the set.
So this was created
in 2007 or 2008?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
So this is kind of
a sped up version.
So--
Those are the Rhine maidens
frolicking in the Rhine.
Mm-hmm.
And then eventually,
they come across--
I think in this version, yeah.
So that becomes a
beach, and then they
comes out with the Rhine.
The Rheingold in those
days was supposed
to be a big golden cloth,
but that all changed.
And then of course,
they're being brought back
into the depths of the Rhine.
And then we had, in those
days, we had Wotan down
and Fricka sleeping.
And, I guess-- so
it shows you a bit
how we played around
with the actual set.
This is, those are
the giants visiting.
Because we kind of tried
to envision the Giants
as two giant hands coming
to them and saying,
we want to be paid.
So we created these giant hands.
And the hands would actually
come and kidnap Freia.
And then after that, they
all decided to go down to,
that's one of the excerpts
that we saw earlier on, when
it becomes a giant staircase.
And decide to go
down to Nibelheim.
[LAUGHING] So, of
course, you have
to understand that
in those days,
we didn't have the vaguest idea
how we were going to do this.
[LAUGHING] We just
thought it would be
an interesting way of doing it.
So then, of course, the set
became the body of the dragon.
And it's interesting
to see it this way,
because it's quite naked.
Because all of this
is, there's a lot
of interactive
projections on this set.
But this was like the bare
bones of the whole piece.
So, I don't know if we have
the equivalent for Walküre
or for the others.
But I think that's--
That's pretty much it.
--what we've got, yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
Are there any other
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
of the Ring?
Well, maybe, just to maybe
give you an example of--
people think I'm obsessed by
big machines and technology
and all that.
I always end up working
with these things,
but I'm interested
in low tech, also.
And in the very beginning
of how you use technology.
And I did this
other opera that's
performing right now, who was
performing, because they're
on strike in Lyon.
But this week, I had the
Nightingale, a Stravinsky piece
that I've been working on.
And we went to Vietnam to meet
with some Vietnamese water
puppet masters.
And the whole
adventure that time
was to convince opera houses
to empty the orchestra pit,
to put the orchestra on
stage, to fill the orchestra
pit with water.
We have not done
that at the Met.
[LAUGHTER]
And the actual singers
are waist deep in water
and manipulate Vietnamese
water puppets and sing.
So maybe we have some
excerpts of that.
We could show you some of the
stuff that we've managed to do.
And that's in Lyon right
now, and it's been--
so in this case,
there's no projections,
there's no engineering.
It's good old puppetry.
And so we have bunraku
puppetry involved.
And this is actually a singer.
And the chorus in
the back all had
to learn how to manipulate
Taiwanese style puppets.
And--
It's really fantastic.
So this is one of the
excerpts of the piece.
We also, in the first
part of that opera,
we also worked with very,
very, very low tech.
With a lot of shadowplay.
So maybe we could show you some
excerpts of the first part.
It's a rare Stravinsky
piece that's rarely done.
And so there's a
lot of hand shadows,
and that's all
done live on stage.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[OPERA MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
And the audience gets
to see both, right?
Yeah, absolutely.
Because that's one of the things
that I think is interesting.
Because yesterday,
I part of a panel
about the world of illusions,
and theatrical illusions,
and all that.
And how one of the
important things
about any kind of illusion,
or the use of technologies,
is to actually have
confidence in the audience
and their intelligence.
And actually show them
how things are made.
So people actually see on
the side all of the hand
shadow and all that.
But, of course, the
human eye is always
more interested in fantasy.
So you eventually always
look for the fantastical.
I did a show once called
The Far Side of the Moon
where I would kind of
crawl on the floor,
and I had a mirror
in diagonal, and you
would get the illusion that I
was actually floating in space.
And of course, all
of this was exposed.
The audience could see me
dragging myself on the floor,
and they would see the
effect up in the mirror.
And even though they
would see how I do it,
they would always be
drawn by the effect.
So, you know, I trust
the audience thirst
for fantasy and for poetry.
I think it's marvelous
the way you do combine
sort of low tech and new.
I remember when we were first
talking about the Ring, when
I was pursuing
you in London, you
were doing an opera at
the Royal Opera House.
Or rather, it was after that.
You were doing the
Anderson Project in London,
and I went to watch that.
It was a wonderful one-man
show, like other one-man shows
you've done, where you
play multiple characters.
And at one point
in the show, you
walk across the stage as one
character, pass behind a tree,
and then emerge
on the other side
without breaking stride
dressed completely differently
as another character.
Yes, those are all old
tricks of the trade.
All--
I remember saying to you
after, how did you do that?
You said, oh, that's
an 18th century--
Yeah.
It's actually a
body double who's
hiding in the tree
who actually--
and then I get to have a glass
of water and I hide a while.
So they're all 19th
century tricks.
So I'm very, very--
I'm fascinated by that,
because I think that we're
in a world of razzmatazz.
We go to see 3D films
and we watch television.
And everything is into special
effects, and all of that.
And very often, you're a bit
alienated by all of that,
because you always go,
how did they do that?
Or how do I do that?
I didn't understand.
How did he do that?
But when you're in
the theater, you
have the possibility to
actually show the strings
and show how it's done, and
give a chance to the audience
to use their intelligence
and their creativity.
And even if they do find how
you do that, it actually, it's
part of the enjoyment
of the whole thing.
When we were talking
about the Ring at first,
I remember you told me
that you had recently
produced, directed, this
new show in Las Vegas.
Was that your first or
second Cirque du Soleil?
It was the first show I
did for Cirque du Soleil.
First show you did for
Cirque du Soleil called KA.
Which you suggested I might
want to go and check out,
because you told me
that you were going
to use some of the
technological ideas
that you developed for that
in the service of the Ring.
Yeah.
And that we would maybe--
maybe Cirque du Soleil
shouldn't hear this-- but
that, basically,
we were going to,
the Met was going to
be the beneficiary
of this $200 million commercial
project in Las Vegas, which
had the most amazing effects.
Obviously, was a
whole different type
of pop culture kind of event.
But some of that technology in
terms of motion control and--
And also interactivity.
--interactivity was, you
developed for that show,
and then used it
now in the Ring.
And actually, I
think in the Ring,
the technology caught
up with the ideas,
which is kind of nice.
But in the days of
Cirque Du Soleil,
there were still very,
very bulky ideas.
And I know we have some clips
of some of these things.
Maybe we could
show, there's the--
maybe the battle scene--
From KA?
From KA.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
We could maybe
show that, where we tried
to use interactive video
for the first time and
some of these effects
have found themselves in, uh.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
So, of course, this looks like
an overhead shot of a battle.
But actually, the whole
stage is vertical,
and they're actually the
thing is happening like this.
And--
So can you explain,
how does it work?
Well, actually, they all have
a harness, and in their hand
they have a little button.
And they actually
pull themselves up
with this little button.
They push on the button
and it determines the speed
at which they go up and down.
And they, so they're
completely independent of the--
But they're being tracked
by infrared sensors?
And then what you see at the
bottom, the water ripples
and all of that, actually the
floor is a sensitive floor
that we created, that
we invented at Cirque du
Soleil in 2003, I think it was.
So that actually,
the wall in which
you're crashing to do
this knows at what speed
you're coming in, at what
velocity, where you are.
So the video actually
reacts to you.
But, I mean, the
point I wanted to make
with this excerpt is that--
and the same thing
for the Met-- is
that all of these
technologies and these effects
are there to be an echo of
whatever the performer does.
The thing is not to try
to draw the attention.
These effects don't draw
the attention to themselves.
The idea is to try
to magnify whatever
the performers, the
velocity, the strength.
And in the Ring, there's
actually some great moments
where what people see on stage,
let's say it's a snowstorm
or if it's the wind that's
in the trees, all of that
is triggered by the sound
that comes from the pit.
And depending of the sibilance,
the dynamics, the velocity,
whatever happens that night--
Almost all the singers
in the Ring are mic'd.
Yeah.
Not to project their
voices into the theater,
but to help interact
with the scenic effects
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
Exactly.
So a lot of the
effects in the ring
are triggered by whatever the
performance is that night.
And so, of course,
it's very tricky,
because you always have to find
the balance in these things.
And you don't want this
effect to draw attention
to themselves.
But of course, there's
always that risk,
as people have never seen these
things for the first time.
They, of course, they--
I know last night, after the
showing of the film at Tribeca,
Jay Hunter Morris, who was this
miraculous discovery who was
a cover for the
role of Siegfried--
possibly the hardest tenor
role in all of opera--
who stepped in three
days before the premiere,
because the tenor who was
supposed to sing it wasn't well
and couldn't go on.
And Jay was saying last
night that he realized,
because he was not
familiar with the set,
he had to get
familiar very fast.
So as he was walking across
the set in the love duet
with Brunhilde that takes
place at the end of Siegfried
when he discovers her, and
he's the hero who unlocks her
from the sleep that she's been
sentenced to by her father,
he realized that
as he was walking,
leaves were moving around
the stage that were--
Virtual leaves.
--interactive virtual leaves.
And when he kicked one, it
actually moved out of the way.
[LAUGHTER]
So he was surprised.
He was surprised as
he interacted himself.
Which also, I think, added to
the wonder of his performance,
perhaps.
Well, that's an
interesting thing.
Because actually, when you do
get to work with the singers,
and some of them,
of course, are so
preoccupied by being heard, and
being there where they should
be in the score, and having
eye contact with the conductor.
And also trying to perform and
trying to be a good listener.
So an opera singer's mind is
very, very busy when he sings.
And you know, you try
to say, well, there's
also all this world around
you that if ever you
want to use it, use it.
So, of course, some singers,
and certainly the singers
who sing the part
for the first time
will be less generous
with you on that aspect.
But people like Bryn Terfel and
[INTERPOSING VOICES] who know
the part so well and [INAUDIBLE]
great would climb on the set
when it's not time to
climb on it, and would do,
say I want to ride this.
I want to ride it.
And actually have fun with
the interaction and the video
and all that.
So I think with
time, people will
get used to these new tools
and these new possibilities,
I think.
So right now, I wasn't
really aware of this
until I asked to see what
you were doing at the moment,
and in the world.
You have-- there's a
list here somewhere.
You actually have,
this very moment, four
different theatrical shows.
Lip Sync, Blue Dragon,
the Anderson Project,
and a new show called Spades
that I don't know about.
Which all of them are on tour.
In the case of Spades,
it's opening in two weeks.
You have the Ring
playing at the Met.
You have Nightingale, Rossignol,
possibly playing in Lyon
if the strikers
come back to work.
You have two Cirque Du Soleil
shows playing simultaneously.
One is TOTEM.
TOTEM is coming
to Boston in June.
You have your annual
architectural visual project,
the Image Mill.
So it's no wonder you're
hard to get hold of.
And then in the creative
oven right now, you have--
what do you have-- another show.
Maybe you could
explain what Spades
is, because there's
another playing card
show called Diamonds.
Which is--
Well, actually, Spades is
part of the playing card--
Right.
And the Tempest at the Met--
And the Tempest.
--a contemporary
opera by Thomas Ades
that has already had two
productions since its premiere
in London 2004 or 2005.
Four, yeah.
And which you just
were working on--
Workshopping.
Workshopping last week.
Close to Montreal.
Yeah.
So, so this is quite exciting.
So how do you do all
these things at once?
Well, I'm very well organized,
very well structured.
I have-- I'm a very,
very chaotic person.
The way, I work in a
very intuitive way.
So.
Nobody is doing-- has
this many shows going on
at the same time.
Well, maybe--
That I know of.
--Bob Wilson probably
has a few of those.
And I could name a few--
He's moved at a slower pace.
OK, yeah, of course.
For some reason, as I get older.
I get more and more stuff.
Like, no.
But the thing that
has to be known
is that I work in a
very, very intuitive way.
I don't work in an intellectual
organized way and all that.
But I have tons of people
around me to help me out.
But it all takes place in where
Robert works, his headquarters,
which you developed
in the '90s, I guess,
is this converted
firehouse barracks.
It was a firehouse and
the sleeping quarters--
Yeah.
--called La...?
La Caserne.
La Caserne, which
means that, I guess.
Yeah.
Where all the creative
stuff happens.
Yeah, pretty much.
That's the starting place.
So.
So how many people do you
have in there doing something?
Well, maybe we have at
La Caserne, maybe 20
some people who are permanent.
But there's, like, hundreds of
people that work there a year.
And we work also with, we
co-produce and exchange
with a lot of people
around the world.
But I think the
idea-- and not saying
there's a secret recipe
to be able to do so
many things at the same time.
It's just that you have to
be not only well-supported,
well-structured,
well-organized by extremely
intelligent and structured
people around you.
But you also have to leave
time for things to happen.
So for example, when we started
working on the Ring five, six
years ago, and you work on
the Ring for maybe two weeks,
and then you let it
there for four months.
And in the meantime, you're
working on a new opera,
or on another show,
on a creation,
or on the circus show.
And they also go through
the same kind of process.
So after a while, you can
actually manage a lot of things
at the same time.
And they kind of cook, and
it's slow food, they call it.
So I'm very privileged
now because I'm
in a position where
I never say yes
to a project that's going
to happen this summer
or in the fall.
I say, OK, and what year?
And how can we space out the
development phases of that
project?
And I think that's
part of the secret.
Because a lot of stuff happens
in the back of your head
that you don't know about
between these sessions.
You work on, let's
say, we'd rehearse
for three weeks on a
project, and then everybody
disappears for four months.
And during that
four months, you're
not thinking of the project.
But something in the
back of your head,
your subconscious actually
mends stuff, finds solutions.
So that when we come back--
So that's good for the creator.
Absolutely, yeah.
And all of these projects
inform each other.
So sometimes the answer to
a problem on one project
will be found in the other
project and all that.
So that's also a very
intricate system.
And you can't command that.
That happens.
It just happens that way.
Do you want to, are
there any other examples
of current stuff that you--
I don't know.
--you're doing that
you'd like to talk about?
How about the Image Mill?
Which is this annual
visual event that
started a couple of years ago.
It's in Quebec City.
Yeah.
Where you--
So at this place that you
were mentioning earlier
on the Caserne, which is the
fire hall or studio or lab
in Quebec City where we
develop most of our things,
we have a lot of
interesting creative minds
that gravitate around us.
It feels, at times,
a bit like MIT.
And that's why I feel a bit
at home here in that sense.
We have some really
interesting minds.
And so the Image
Mill was created
during the 2008 celebrations of
the 400th anniversary of Quebec
City.
So I had been commissioned
to do some kind of event,
and we chose to do
the world's largest
architectural projection.
It's actually 0.6
kilometers long.
It's in the Guinness
Book of Records.
Well, if I'm going to brag
about something, [INAUDIBLE]..
And, well, maybe we
could show some images
as we're speaking, just to give
you an idea of the scope of it.
Or the, and what it is.
So here you see it's in
the harbor in Quebec City.
And those are 86 grain
silos, the building
that you see there.
It's this huge, huge,
huge, huge thing
that's actually
blocking the view
from the river in Quebec City.
So we decided to transform it
into some kind of projection
surface.
And we managed, with time, to
add 3D effects and all that.
So this is a result of
projections that we do.
We pretend that the silos
actually reveal their content,
and it's quite a big-- so this
is in the context of the city.
You see how big it is.
And so it's seen from
every point in the city,
and people gather in
the harbor to see it.
But also, it's seen
from hotel rooms,
and its soundtrack is on a
radio channel that people can,
so it's quite a big event.
People come by boat.
There's also people that visit
the river during the daytime,
and then they all kind of
park their boats in the harbor
and come to see.
And, basically, what
it does is the history
of Quebec City, which is the
oldest city in North America,
in fact.
And so it's the story of four
different centuries, the four
centuries and what
they're about.
So there's a lot of archives--
How many projectors do you--
It's done with 20--
in fact, it's 25 high
definition projectors,
but there's probably 28,
because there's always
one that goes wrong.
It's always-- you
know about that.
There's always something that
goes wrong at these big things.
And it's all synchronized
by the same computer.
So it's a big team that
works on that every year,
and it's quite an
event, and it's
part of the signature
of the city now.
That's fantastic.
Of course, the downside of
using all this technology
is that when things do go wrong,
you feel a little bit helpless.
[LAUGHING] Yeah, of course.
We've had our-- I
mean, but that's OK.
That's part of the
sport of theater.
That's always what I say.
I mean, just because we got
accustomed to the guillotine
of the opening night of a movie.
You can't change a movie.
The movie's out, it's
there, distributed.
We can't do anything.
But theater, it's
a living animal.
And it changes.
And of course, some evenings--
[INTERPOSING VOICES] the Ring
has changed the entire culture
and atmosphere of the
Met in terms of inside
the Met is the stage crew.
We have 200 stagehands
who work at the Met
in order to move the
scenery in and out of
and to operate shows.
We're a repertory
theater with seven
shows a week, two different
operas on Saturday, matinee
and an evening performance.
And a stage that is in
constant use, where we have
a rehearsal in the daytime.
Today, for example,
we were rehearsing
a revival of Billy Budd.
And now, right at
this moment, the crew
is frantically making sure
that all the connections
in the machine are ready
for tonight's performance
of Rheingold.
But what's different
about the Ring in terms
of the culture of the Met
and the way the crew works
is that for the
first time, they've
never had to interact
with scenery like this.
Because as computerized
and advanced
as the Ring is, ultimately
as you evolve the designs,
it came down to stagehands
also manipulating the planks
and holding the
planks and having
to, in a lot of the
stage, lifts of the Met
being used to introduce
various scenic elements.
So it's interactive between
people and the machinery.
And it's become, also, a bit
puppet-like in a certain way.
It's puppetry.
And I have to say that
the crew at the Met
have been so proud
of the whole project.
They love it.
And they've invested
themselves so much into this,
and they're so proud of
the whole production.
And they've put so much
creative energy and--
Well, they love-- they've
never been so stimulated.
I mean, because every stagehand
gets to really be involved--
Absolutely.
--in a way they
normally wouldn't be.
Yeah.
I thought it would be
interesting, perhaps,
to talk a little bit.
Once you said to me, I remember
some months ago that you,
I don't know if you
were actually a busker.
But you said that
you grew up with sort
of this uniquely gifted
group of Quebecois citizens
who all sort of come
from the same generation,
including Guy--
Guy Laliberte.
Guy Laliberte, the founder
of Cirque Du Soleil.
So is that, how did you begin?
I mean--
Well, actually, I studied
at the conservatory
to become an actor.
But--
In Canada?
In Quebec City.
And so when I came out
of the conservatory,
I didn't think I'd have
a career as an actor,
because I didn't have any
casting for anything, you know.
And in those days, it was very,
very kind of flower power.
And we were very much
into collective writing
and doing political
theater and all that.
So I was pretty much
doing that kind of thing.
We would do stuff and
we'd play in the street
and we'd make the money
that people would give us.
And it was very influenced
by the Bread and Puppet
and the Living Theater
and whatever movement
was going on here in
the United States.
And never really
thought that I'd
have a career as an
actor or a director.
And, you know, just I always
did this small little troupes
and didn't have
any big ambitions.
And, eventually, it
kind of caught on,
and we started
touring the world.
And people start to be very
interested in our work.
Touring on your own,
or with a group?
With a group.
With a company.
And for some reason, our
work moved and interested,
and people identified ourselves
to what we were doing.
And suddenly, we started
co-producing with people
from all over the world, and
we became very much in demand.
And but I always remembered that
when I was in the conservatory,
I was interested in
acting and all that.
But I spent way too much
time with the people
doing production I was very
interested in sound editing
and lighting design and
all these other things.
And I'd always get flak from--
my teachers would say you're
spending way too much time
on these things, and you should
be working more on your acting,
and all that.
So from the very,
very beginning I've
always had a finger
in every pie,
and I never thought that that
would actually be a quality.
It's always been seen as a flaw.
And so with time--
so it creates a kind of
conscience of what theater is
and how.
And you have to be, I mean, if
you want theater to survive,
you have to be interested
in all these things.
You've not only
worked as an actor,
you've worked as
a dancer recently.
Recently.
At age 50.
At age 50, Sylvie Guillem,
who's an amazing dancer, who's
a star dancer, showed up at
a performance of the Anderson
Project in Australia
and said, well, I'd
like to work with you.
And I said fine.
And but I thought she wanted me
to direct her, or to help her.
Because I knew she
wanted to maybe find
a way to become an actress.
So I said, well, fine.
And we had a few
meetings and all that.
And at one point
I said, you know,
Sylvie, I'm not sure
that I'm the right person
to work with you because
I'm not a choreographer
and I'm not sure I
understand very well.
Well, she said, I don't
want you to choreograph me
or to direct me.
I want to dance with you.
And with Sylvie Guillem--
You didn't have to say yes.
Well, no.
But if Sylvie Guillem
comes up to you
and she says, I want to
dance with you, you know,
you have to say yes to that.
So I was at least 35 pounds
larger, bigger, heavier,
whatever you say.
And I said, my god,
this is suicidal.
But I said, why not?
And we got together
and developed
this extraordinary story
about Chevalier [INAUDIBLE],,
and it's a long and
difficult to explain.
And it's classical dance,
modern dance, theater,
influenced by a lot of martial
arts and all these things.
And a year later,
I was dancing--
I was dancing at Sadler's
Wells and we just recently
came back from Japan.
And--
It's a good way to
keep your weight down.
Well, that's the problem.
Is that I'm a squeezebox.
I'm an accordion.
It's just that every
time we do the show,
I have to lose a lot of weight
to fit in my Alexander McQueen
tights.
And after that,
when the show is off
and there's a six month
period between shows,
I just kind of
become this thing.
So, but it's extraordinary.
And it's great
because you think,
and of course,
Sylvie now is maybe,
I don't know exactly what
age she is, she's, you know,
she's not in her 20s anymore.
And she still
works, and she still
is an amazing, amazing artist.
And so it kind of was a
good example for me to say,
well, you know,
retirement's not an option.
I think you could
always learn at any age.
And I like being surprised in
my career by things like that.
Suddenly somebody shows up in
your dressing room and says,
I want to dance with you.
And you're 50, and you're out
of breath, and you want to die,
and you have to--
so, it's, I mean, I like
life life changing things.
And the same thing
happened with you
when you showed up at
Covent Garden and said,
you want to do the Ring?
And I went, [GROANS]
oh, my gosh.
And you're, well, yeah, why not?
Somebody offers you to
climb Mount Everest,
you have to do it.
You know?
So I know.
I like that.
I mean, I'm afraid
somebody tonight
is going to come up to
me and suggest something.
I don't know, [GROANS].
But, I don't know.
It's the kind of thing,
it's the kind of accident
you like to bump into.
The kind of thing
that's life changing.
So what are some of the
future Mount Everests for you?
I know you have this
extraordinary theater project.
You're building
a theater, right?
Yeah, we're building
a theater right now.
Can you talk about that?
Yeah.
Because we have the Caserne in
Quebec City, but we just have,
we just received
part of the funding
to actually build a
new room in Quebec
City, an actual theater
where we, let's actually
design for our work.
And where we'll also be
presenting maybe small operas,
circus shows.
It's going to be, it's going
to, a place called the Diamond.
And the reason why
it's called the Diamond
because a diamond
has multiple, it's
multifaceted, like our work.
But also because Quebec City
is built on Cape Diamond,
because the French thought that
there was a lot of-- that's
why they settled there.
They saw these diamonds,
this shiny stuff.
Of course, it's not
diamonds at all.
And also because when I
opened that first century
20 some years ago, Bob
Wilson was elegant enough
to send me a video
message where he said,
our cities need centers,
a diamond in an apple,
which is a very Bob
Wilson thing to say.
A diamond in an apple.
Of course.
And so he said congratulations
to Robert Lepage's center,
and blah, blah, blah.
And I said, well,
this is a nice image.
A diamond in an apple.
And it's true.
I mean, I think that our
cultural centers, whether it's
the Lincoln Center or
the Met or whatever,
this place here has to be,
that's what we have to.
Have to be like a shining jewel.
And with all of the alchemic
notions of what a jewel is.
Can you describe some of these
shows you have in the works
right now?
There's a lot of them.
But maybe I'd describe
one because it's very
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
But the one about
the playing cards.
And also has to do with what
I did here this week at MIT.
Is that part of the
MIT events, because I
was getting a workshop
with some of the,
I talked to some of
the students here
about this theme
of playing cards.
And so after doing the
Ring, a four part epic,
I'm doing yet another four
part epic on playing cards.
And of course, the first
part is called Spades,
the second is Hearts, the
third one is Diamonds,
and the last one is Clubs.
And it's a very, very,
very long project.
It's going to be
12 hours of theater
eventually and all that.
But we're premiering in Madrid,
in two weeks from now, Spades.
And it's, so, it's
just a group of people
that got together
and started writing
all these extraordinary stories
about playing cards, which
is a very, very inspiring
object or sensitive resource.
And--
So it's a collective--
It's a collective effort.
So that's pretty much
what I'll be doing when I
[INAUDIBLE] off tomorrow.
You're going to Madrid tomorrow?
Well, I'm, no, I'm
going to Quebec City
to sort out what we're going
to be doing in Madrid two weeks
from now.
But it's a three hour show,
and it's quite extraordinary
because it's set in Las Vegas
the weekend when Celine Dion
show premiered at, that was in
like, again, in 2002 or 2003.
And it's that weekend where
she premiered her show
at Caesar's Palace.
And it's the same
weekend when the Allies
started to bomb Baghdad.
So it's about two deserts
and about two separate set
of events that are
interconnected.
And so, yeah.
So it's a crazy project.
Sounds great.
We have a new production
of Rigoletto next season
set in Las Vegas.
Oh, really?
See, there's ripoffs everywhere.
1960.
[LAUGHING] Been
there, done that.
Bought the t-shirt.
You're not directing
it, don't worry.
Should we ask the audience
if they have any questions?
Yep.
I think that we have
microphones standing by for you
that will be brought in.
And Phillip is going to--
There they are.
--come to our moderating aid.
[INAUDIBLE]
That is, if there
are any questions.
[INAUDIBLE] need
you to come down.
Thank you very much.
Oh.
Oh, there are some questions.
And in the MIT tradition, if
you would just state your name,
and very briefly, who
you are, what you are.
I'm, hello.
My name is Rhiannon.
I'm a member of homo
sapiens sapiens, human.
First I just want to
say, Monsieur Lepage,
you're like a rock star to me.
My kind of people.
I'm like your groupie right now.
So.
Yeah.
You're my Elvis.
[LAUGHING] (IMITATING ELVIS)
A-thank you very much.
No, yeah.
No hip wiggles
necessary, don't worry.
My question has to do
with people like me.
I just graduated from
college with a degree
in music and technology.
And theater is my life.
I'm part of Alpha Psi Omega.
I love being on stage, off
stage, backstage, building
the stage, whatever stage.
But the problem is, I just
graduated college with a music
and technology degree.
I don't have any money.
I don't have any time.
I'm trying to work,
trying to get a house.
Real life is scary.
So my question to you, before
I can win the McDermott Award
and do the Ring
Cycle, what do I do?
I'm kind of--
[LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE]
--I'm kind of lost here.
I'm wondering, I
don't have the tools.
I don't have tools.
I don't have a workshop,
I don't have the contacts,
and I don't have the
money to get any of it.
What's my first step?
Well, I--
Save me.
I have to admit that the
funding, the arts funding here
in this country is still
a big mystery to me.
I don't really
know how it works.
I know there's some very
generous people around who
could help you out,
but I know also,
that isn't
necessarily a priority
for governments or for--
so that I know that in Canada,
we do have that great advantage
that we have subsidies.
But this being said,
my company is not,
I don't get that much
money from the governments.
We get nearly 12%
of our of the money
that we generate
because we actually
understood very
early in the process
that we had to go
elsewhere to find it.
That we traveled and we started
doing adventures with people.
And there are people who are
ready to risk years in advance
to work with you.
They'll give you
the money upfront
and say, well, when you're
ready, when the work is ready.
So sometimes when we
can't find the solutions
in our own surroundings we
have to kind of move around.
And maybe you have to
emigrate to Canada.
Or embark on any kind
of venture with people
abroad and eventually be
recognized as an artist.
There are theater programs in
companies in this country that
have apprentice
programs, and if that's--
there are different ways of
getting your foot in the door.
Hm, thank you.
Also will you dance with me?
Thank you very much.
Please.
Yeah.
Hi.
My name's Matt Gray.
I actually teach acting
and directing here
at Northeastern
University, and I also
have a Canadian
passport, so it's
nice to see a familiar face.
I'm really interested in sort
of some nuts and bolts things.
The theater kind of
traditional timeline
is the tech at the end.
And so many of your
pieces over the years,
both in theater
and also in opera,
integrate technology
so beautifully
in the storytelling.
I'm curious, at
what point do they
begin to enter into the
process with the performers,
how they respond to it, and
how important that process is
to you?
Well, very often,
it's from day one.
I know that Brecht, at
the end of his life,
Brecht was working on
this idea that everybody
has to be in the
rehearsal room on day one,
even if they don't
have much to do.
They should be there.
And, of course, that's a
very expensive process.
But there's people who are
ready to do that for very cheap.
And I know that,
for example, when
I did the far side of the
moon, was a one man show.
But the room was crowded with
people, with technicians,
and all that, who didn't
have, didn't know, really,
what the use of them was.
But they just sit there
and they participate
in the conversations
and all that.
And eventually,
people do drawings.
And very, very early on in the
process they suggest stuff,
and you start.
And certainly in
this day and age
where everybody has a
PowerBook and goes on the web,
and I would do an improv
and somebody, some lighting
designer or technician
would say, you know,
the guy you were quoting, well,
actually, the quote is this.
And then there's this
whole thing that happens.
So now I think we
have the tools, very
accessible and cheap tools,
to invite a lot of people
in the rehearsal room.
And not to desacralize
the rehearsal room
that's usually reserved to
the director and the actor.
But to, because my work
is also a writing process,
I think that if everybody
there has their say,
chances are their technologies
or their craft will
be better integrated, will seem
more essential to the work,
because it's informed
from day one.
So what happens is that you
destroy all of the hierarchy.
They use this
hierarchy of the writer
and then the director and
then the slave actors,
and then after that.
And then we bring
in the technicians.
And it's like that because
just for practical reasons
or economical reasons.
So if you could find a way to
make it current economically
to have people from
day one, everybody
there in the room,
and everybody knows
what the project is about.
I think.
Of course, in opera,
that's not possible.
Well, it was in part
when we did the Ring.
Because when we rehearsed in
[INAUDIBLE] close to Montreal--
No, I'm saying
with the singers--
We had a crew--
The singers, the singers.
We didn't have the singers, but
we did have part of the crew,
and we did have a lot
of people in that room.
Yes, sir.
Hi, I'm David Fillingham.
I graduated from Brandeis
University in 1981
with a music degree, and I
went to the old Met '62 to '70.
And it feels to me that a lot
of the great set designers,
like Zeffirelli, et cetera,
are being very much ignored
these days.
I appreciate what
you do very much.
I'm not in any way
suggesting otherwise.
I was with Bread and Puppet
Theater from '70 to '76
and we come from the same world.
But it seems to me
that a lot of art
is mediated through
electronics these days
rather than the beauty
of the art itself.
And certainly, the mechanical
brilliance of Zeffirelli
and people like that
makes some of what
we do look, excuse me for saying
it this way, but pedestrian.
Could you talk a little
bit about art and design
as opposed to technology
and design, please?
Yeah.
Well I would just like to say,
since you mentioned the word
Zeffirelli, I feel that's
partly my territory.
So, you know, Zeffirelli's
in his 80s now.
And in his time, he was a
great theatrical innovator,
and he did wonderful
productions.
But his time was then.
All art forms need to advance
through the current generations
of master directors
and designers.
And certainly, as far
as the Met is concerned,
we do not ask for the Met to
be overrun with technology.
What we ask is great
storytelling directors
to create their best work
at the Met with the tools
that they wish to bring in
as part of that process.
So there are directors who
at the Met this past season,
for example, we have
seven new productions.
David McVicar, who's a very
accomplished stage director,
directed a new production
of Anna Bolena, which
there's nothing, there
are no projections.
It's all just old
fashioned scenery,
but presented with
a modern aesthetic.
All the scene changes to take
place in front of the audience.
We don't bring in the heavy
curtain in between each scene.
You know, it's really what
makes theater and opera
interesting today is the
wealth of imagination that
comes from different directors
who work in creating new work.
So everything has
to move forward.
What Zeffirelli did in the '70s
and '60s was terrific then,
but it's not so terrific now.
You know, it's not, what's
not interesting, I think,
for an audience today is to
see every inch of the Met
proscenium stuffed with scenery.
Sometimes in some of
these older productions,
the scenery may
look interesting,
but you have no
idea who is singing.
So what we're trying
to do is bring
in directors who are trying
who are in touch with
and who are creating the
sensibilities and sensitivities
and leading audiences today.
And ultimately, with the
goal of pleasing them.
Well, something,
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[INTERPOSING VOICES] if I
could, just that in the '60s,
we had no confusion about who
was singing and what the sets
were.
Well.
Well, something,
though, if you come
to see the Tempest, for example,
that we're producing this year,
it is without very, very,
very, very little technology
involved.
And we never have this kind of
conversation about technology
on the Tempest.
It's actually more of an homage
to Zeffirelli in a certain way,
where you would happen.
It's a question of context.
Certain pieces, or certain
artistic adventures,
do sometimes ask for
a new vocabulary.
So that sometimes
involves technology.
And of course,
because we are heavily
using excerpts of contexts
where we did experiment a lot
with technology.
So of course, that's
part of our conversation.
But there's many, many,
many, many other contexts
and projects that we have that
have nothing to do with that.
And where we do have
an appreciation of,
and even we even do an
homage to the craft of people
like Zeffirelli or early stage
designers who were amazing,
amazing painters,
amazing image makers.
But I think it's important
that directors have the ability
to draw upon what is available
today to pursue their craft.
You know, movies
today obviously don't
look like they did 30
years ago, 40 years ago.
When Steven Spielberg started
harnessing special effects
on behalf of ET or some of the
wonderful films that he made,
those films couldn't
have been possible
10 or 20 years earlier.
But the result, there's
a whole debate, also,
in the black and white,
the amazing black
and white days of movies.
It was just so fantastic.
And how people, even Cocteau
swore that he'd never
do a color movie.
Because when color
invaded, said,
well, you know, then it's
all about something else.
Not about real.
And then he eventually gave
in at the end of his life
and did a color movie.
It's always, I think,
when new tools come
in and new paintbrushes come
in and new colors come in,
we're always wary of them
and always afraid of them,
because we don't know them,
and fear is always the cause--
it always comes from ignorance.
And because we don't
know about something,
we fear it, in a way.
But then these
things kind of get
introduced into the whole
array of possibilities.
And so when you happen
to be at the cutting
edge of these things,
of course, you're
more vulnerable
to the criticism.
And then if you're
using technologies
that are kind of accepted
or taken for granted.
[INAUDIBLE] So we
actually have time
for one more question,
with apology,
but our guests have
other obligations.
So please, if you would.
Hi, my name is Paulina.
I'm a mechanical
engineer here, and I
went to see Gotterdammerung
with the MIT art scholars,
and it was really magical.
And I think you already
answered my question, so I
might let somebody else go.
But I wanted to ask
whether you said
that people will become
accustomed to the technology
and used to seeing it.
So whether you thought that
would detract from the magic
or detract from the piece.
No, I think that it's a question
of when Eisenstein first
presented the Cuirasse
Potemkin, actually,
there's people who recount
that in that first projection
some people hid
behind their seats
because they thought
the boat was going
to come through the
screen and were distracted
by a lot of these things.
And the first time footlights,
electrical footlights, people
actually wrote about how
electricity should not
be permitted in a theater
because the organic essence
of the candles and all of that.
And if you see too
much the actors,
you won't listen
to them as much.
And what's important
in theater is the text.
And all these things
were, all these comments.
And eventually, people see
the advantage of seeing
the actors better, you know?
And that's what I mean.
So that's why I'm
not, I'm not offended.
And I agree that there's a
lot of dangers and flaws,
and we might have
failed at times.
And maybe in the
case of the Ring,
it was a bit
overwhelming or whatever.
But still, there are
some magical moments
where a more accustomed audience
to these kind of devices
were actually looking at
listening to the singer
while others were
going, what is this?
I've never seen this.
So of course, you know.
And that's fine, and that's
part of the whole process.
And that's why I'm
saying, you know, in 2,
3, 10 years, that'll be part
of what people are used to.
And that's also
something, I think
it's an important question.
Because it has to
do with knowing what
the audience knows
about storytelling.
And 25, 30 years
ago, the audiences
didn't know much about jump
cuts and flash forwards and all
of this vocabulary that
television and rock
videos and whatever movies
that people have seen.
Now people have a vocabulary,
they're very educated people.
Even people who've
never been to school
go, listen to stories, go
to movies and all that.
And there's this whole thing
that's developed with time.
And you have to take that
into account when you
try to convey a story today.
If you don't do
that, and you try
to respect the tradition
and all of that,
people are at the end of
the play before you are.
So you really have to try to
understand where people are,
and how they
understand the story,
and if they're ready to follow
you in any new way of saying
things.
Robert, Peter, just--
you've raised our sights,
you've raised our spirits.
You've done just,
I think, what we
hoped would happen with Robert's
residency here in celebrating
the McDermott Award.
And so we congratulate you.
MIT thanks you.
I hope you'll come back, and
Peter, you're always welcome
back too.
So thank you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
Well done.
[INAUDIBLE] Well done.